validée par le conseil scientifique s'il
s'applique de manière temporaire et
exceptionnelle
le pass annie terre commence à prendre
forme un qr code placé sur les
attestations de vaccination a scanné
ensuite sur l'application tout senti qu
vide
voilà en quoi consiste le certificat
vaccinale appelé à se développer dans
l'hexagone une première étape dans
l'instauration de ce procédé numérique
dont le principe a été voté par le
parlement européen
fin avril le pass sanitaire utilisé de
manière temporaire et exceptionnelle
peut permettre à la population une forme
de retour à la vie normale en minimisant
les risques de contamination par le
virus ars cov deux se passe sanitaire
sera le sésame pour accéder aux
événements sportifs festifs mais aussi
culturelles comme l'a dernièrement
rappelé emmanuel macron en revanche pas
de dispositions prévues pour les bars et
les restaurants
il y a un double aspect la reprise de
l'activité économique et la maîtrise de
l'épidémie et des variants mais
attention parce sanitaire ne veut pas
dire protection absolue
cet outil numérique a pour but
d'empêcher toute fraude en garantissant
la fiabilité des attestations un procédé
toutefois loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de l'opposition
pas de passes annie terre si le vaccin
n'est pas accessible à tous d'où la
nécessité de lever les brevets le
rapport était clair les amendements ont
bien été déposés par notre groupe où
siège la france insoumise prendre
position pour la levée des brevets c'est
bien le voter c'est mieux et pour tous
ceux qui se posent la question
nous nous sommes bien opposés au pass
and i ter qui marque un nouveau recul
des libertés
la position de la france insoumise et
très clair là dessus
l'épidémiologiste en chef emmanuel
macron nous en qui l'air de rien le
passeport vaccinale pour moi il n'est
pas question de droit d'accès à deux
vitesses outre les risques de
stigmatisation qu'il soulève se passe à
l'inconvénient de ne pas reconnaître
tous les vaccins
seuls sont concernés pour l'instant les
sérums autorisés par l'ue eux à savoir
ceux de pfizer biotech astrazeneca
modern art & johnson and johnson